welcome to another thankful thursday
i believe it's important to thank the
people who've had an impact on your life
because
you can't do this alone being an
entrepreneur is hard it's it's one of
the hardest things that you're ever
going to do in your life
and you need the support of people
around you to help you get to where you
want to go
and so today i wanted to thank maturism
materia zam is a youtube artist
and he creates motivational videos some
of the best motivational videos online
he's really the
best at what he does he he's awesome
and i saw some of his videos and for a
while i'd wanted to to have my own
set of videos you know i i love making
these videos this is great this will
continue
but i wanted something else i wanted
people to watch one of the videos and be
left with that
feeling of belief but but feeling like
they're ready to take action you know
sometimes you walk out of a a movie or
you listen to somebody speak and
and you're you're just ready to to do
something you're ready to step up you're
ready to
to go to the next level you're ready to
bust through the fear that you have and
just go
and take action you're ready for action
that's what i wanted i wanted all that
in a video for myself selfishly but also
to share with other people i reached out
to my tourism because he was the best at
what he did
and fortunately he agreed to a
collaboration
and we worked together on a video and
really it was
it was all his work i said you know what
you're an artist i love what you do
your work is amazing it inspires me
the only thing i ask is that the video's
theme is believe
do whatever you want with the rest of it
just make sure that it's about believing
and he created something
that's amazing something that to this
day i watch
every day i wake up i grab my lentils
for breakfast i load my youtube comments
and i play my belief playlist
and the first video always on my believe
playlist is believe by maturism
and that video has had a strong impact
on me and it's
it's impacted hundreds of thousands and
soon millions of people
and i'm forever grateful as a result
i've now made partnerships with other
youtube artists and given them exposure
and following
in the same footsteps where it's
believed by
whoever that artist is and so i just
wanted to take the time today to thank
maturism for
for your collaboration your partnership
it was a great experience it's impacted
a lot of people
and maybe we could do it again
for those of you watching again it's
hard being an entrepreneur and there's a
lot of people who
make sacrifices and go out of their way
to help you
on a regular basis so take time out of
your day today to thank them it could be
a handwritten note
an email a phone call make a video take
them to coffee
just do something doesn't have to cost
you anything just do something to show
your appreciation
and say thank you it'll make you feel
better it'll make them feel better
and it'll supercharge your day believe
those are watching you like this video
you can subscribe to the channel to see
more just like this and i'll see you
soon